welcome to this video again some pizza
okay but it's got a pretty high rating
for a pizza hmm let's see and well II
six that's a funny set up yeah he's
probably playing for d5 hmm I don't know
I'm very do it like that I don't know if
or d5 might be might make some sense for
black ok ok I'm going to play normal
moose this looks like a weird kind of
green felt with e 697 plate the problem
might be that is not so easily playing
c5 and this formation ok yeah let's do a
push-up e2 and just castle looks like
simple way to play well what is this
guy's rating profile let's check that
I'd like to check the other ratings
pretty high yeah because frankly this is
just a very bad opening play so I really
should try to punish that is some
structure is terrible we should bomb on
c6 vette bishop on b7 and it's full of
dark squared weaknesses so that's a
somewhat weird way to play for such a
high rated player let's see that's going
to happen he has a hard time to loose
the C or B pond and I will get a night
to see 5 okay so directly or I can go a
form that is also quite promising well
that's also quite promising let's do
that but not clear what's what's better
just 94 or a form but provoking deform
is probably not a bad idea and if he
takes Knight eggs that's also a very
very nice structure
night would come to to c5 yeah that's
interesting now yeah i'm going to play
Bishop b5 and he definitely cannot trade
the bishops this would completely kill
any dark squares so he has to play f6 I
guess Bishop to d6 mm-hmm well even 96
as a move but I think just going back is
a decent idea I have 96 still still as
an option it was interesting even right
away maybe that was strong even but 96
is a huge threat and I don't really see
what he's doing against it hmm oh I know
how you just read it is but it looks
very very comfortable getting a night to
d6 yeah if you have bishops on b7 and g7
and pawns on c6 and f6 something's
something's off yeah I don't know what
is he doing here is 96 now pretty good i
mean the position and well sucked anyway
but in 497 he doesn't I don't see a
tactical or anything of the like how
does he handle this now this is bishop
issue I don't even see how he yeah
moving it back I can take c6 now I can
take let's let's think about this for a
moment it can also take c 8 which would
force Queen takes I can also take c 6
which is probably
yeah holy probably the easiest to play
threatening Bishop a six now and on
ninth Cesar 98 and I'm covering this
night which is nice nice to do yeah yeah
that looks like the only idea to to make
to create some kind of kind of confusion
um yeah what to do I can just take c8
actually this is also not bad or bishop
edge form Bishop age form Queen B seven
then take on c 8 or take on a six I
don't know I can just take a bishop a
six also
I don't know Bishop a6 the rook will be
kind of offside on a six which looks a
bit strange I can also just take a form
is there anything wrong with that
probably not let's just do it I don't
see anything wrong with that move
don't want to spend too much time them
and so here I can take I was thinking f5
actually and it's okay McQueen d7 maybe
mmm i probably had something better
right i mean this looks looks nice still
but it seems like i should have had
something better okay
let's moving back with this Bishop
they're only five yeah I'm now after
that definitely misplayed that somehow I
must have had something better than this
I mean it's not a bad position but that
this was something where black should
shouldn't be alive anymore uh-huh so
what are we going to do here night years
go to e8 casco here right before I am
can I can take it Bishop c6 of bishop d6
ok after watch out going to have a bit
slow here
time warning sure I'm pawn up and have a
good position and still it wasn't that
wasn't the best way to play it it's
quite clear
what do I do okay let's just cover that
for the moment but I could have taken a
seven right I should have done that
before
maybe he can take on g2 somehow for the
petrol rock g to know even no way wait
wait and am I losing here that would be
really frustrating I think he could have
taken really i think it could have taken
check
paratively checkmate no Jack Black
forfeits on time well I had one hit
checkmate in one move yeah well the
worst thing is no I should never ever
have gotten to that I mean here this
this game should be home when about ten
moves or so but I did not I did not
finish this off so computer agrees up to
this point and now night xe8 was winning
yeah I Trixie eight you know what I did
not think about I can just after that I
can just take here of course I was just
thinking okay well i will recapture
somehow but of course i didn't need to i
can just take a 6cm yeah well this is
like plus two still but not not as
convincing a teen night b7 is stronger
Kim okay I always keep this plus 2 thing
no night be seven wins apiece out what a
game I was I was too irritated that
still plus formed yeah the position is
so bad you can you can make a couple of
mistake and mistakes and still and still
plus two yeah but I started to do stupid
things he I should pick a 7 immediately
this is just a stupid move I can just
take a seven now and and it's what it is
two pawns right yeah I should just take
the pawn that that was was kind of
stupid okay now I took it and now 95 is
just just just just a terrible blunder
because he can't eat I which he did not
do I don't know why its kind of jack
this is a check this is a drawl he can
shut do this I'm escaping him funny
enough check getting check I have Queen
III actually yeah so I'm escaping here
and here I'm better again after this I
was glad to take Queens off simply
because of the shock of Luke g2 I mean
that's not the best move probably but I
wanted to be a bit save them and yet I
think him okay lived here I could have
could have actually taken the pawn okay
well I had 20 seconds Janet we needed to
be quickly but of course I I mr. i miss
this one affected 10 i have 13 seconds I
was kind of panicking a little bit okay
now all it said was it well it was a
putz a fool game so there was some
Patsos in this game for both sides okay
well i hope you enjoyed this roller
coaster thanks for watching